hypothesis-driven research is the
process of
forming
and testing
and even rejecting hypotheses in order
to get closer and closer to the best
hypothesis
the best possible answer for a
scientific question it's a very
systematic way to do science because the
answers are based on data and collecting
evidence
but some scientists do what we call
descriptive research which is more
exploratory research when they're trying
to collect a lot of information
and the best end result of doing that
kind of research is to find a good
hypothesis and do hypothesis driven
research hypothesis-driven research is
an important concept for students to
understand because it's the primary way
we do science it's the primary way that
we answer scientific questions to
understand the natural worlds and
construct explanations that are based on
evidence
the first step of hypothesis driven
research is finding a scientific
question
and a scientific question is something
that you're trying to answer about the
natural world and to be a scientific
question it has to be one that you can
answer by making observations by doing
experiments and by
testing it
so what is your favorite flower
is a good question but it's not a good
scientific question
because the answers to that question
are based on subjective opinions and
values
it's hard to test it
so a better scientific question might be
something like this
do butterflies of a particular species
prefer to visit flowers of a specific
color
that is a better scientific question
because it's one that we can test
the second step of hypothesis driven
research is forming a hypothesis
hypothesis is a possible
and tentative answer to a scientific
question
and to be a good hypothesis it has to
have three conditions it has to be
specific and clear
it has to be testable and it has to be
this is really important falsifiable
meaning the ability to be proven false
or rejected
if we think about the scientific
question do butterflies prefer to visit
flowers of a particular color one
possible hypothesis for that question is
butterflies prefer to visit red colored
flowers
that's something that we can test
I can go into nature or go into the lab
and do Choice experiments and see if
butterflies actually spend more time
visiting certain colored flowers
it's also falsifiable I use my
hypothesis to predict what's going to
happen in the experiment and I try to
test it and I try to actually reject
that hypothesis
when you set up an experiment and you
start with an initial hypothesis
in order to to test that hypothesis we
have to rewrite it
as two competing claims and those two
competing claims are the null hypothesis
and the alternative hypothesis
the null hypothesis
predicts in your experiment that there's
going to be no relationship between the
variables being tested
the alternative hypothesis states that
there is a relationship between the
variables being tested
in your experiment so for our question
about butterflies preferring flowers of
a particular color the null hypothesis
might be that flower color has no effect
on butterflies visiting flowers
the alternative hypothesis would be
flower color does have an effect on the
frequency that butterflies visit flowers
so we start with a good hypothesis that
helps us make predictions to set up a
well-designed experiment what is a
well-designed experiment it's one that
has a control group maybe multiple
control groups and experimental groups
the difference between those two groups
is
the variable that we're trying to test
we want those groups to be exactly the
same except the experimental group is
gonna
have that one variable that we're trying
to test red colored flowers
so if I was setting up an experiment to
test my hypothesis I would want to make
sure that all the butterflies were the
same species the same age they were all
equally motivated equally hungry to
visit flowers
I would want to make sure that the
flowers I present are exactly the same I
would probably use artificial flowers so
I could control smell and what the
flowers look like to make everything
exactly the same the only thing I'm
going to vary is that independent
variable which is flower color and I
collect lots of data during that
experiment I want to have a very large
sample size because what I'm going to
want to do is analyze that data using
statistics
foreign
so if I wanted to test the null
hypothesis that there's no relationship
between flower color and time spent by
butterflies visiting the flowers
I'm going to use statistics to analyze
if there is a significant difference
between those variables are butterflies
actually spending more time visiting
flowers of a particular color or is the
variation the natural variation I might
see in the experiment only due to chance
a statistical analysis will allow me to
determine that based on the results
of that analysis I'm either going to
support or I'm going to reject the null
hypothesis
if I reject the null hypothesis my
evidence is supporting the alternative
hypothesis
so if the butterflies spend more time
significantly more time visiting red
colored flowers then I would reject the
null hypothesis that there isn't a
relationship between those variables
there actually is a relationship between
the dependent and the independent
variable
it's important to not be wed to your
hypothesis
[Music]
the process of hypothesis driven
research is to reject hypotheses it's
not about being right
in fact oftentimes scientists have to go
back to the drawing board
and come up with new hypothesis because
their evidence shows otherwise so be
open to having your hypothesis rejected
because you might make a big discovery
that you wouldn't have seen in another
case
foreign